Having correlation between
our predictor variables,
will not cause much issue during the
building of a classification model, but
will cause issues during
the prediction time.
Let's go through the list of potential
predictor variables and use logic and
correlation to remove duplicate or
inter-correlated variables.
If we look at the top two most
associated variables to churn,
they are total day in minutes and
total day in charges.
If we logically think about it,
I would assume that
the amount a person is charged on
their phone bill for daytime calls
would be directly related to how many
minutes they talked during the day.
On the left side, we have
a correlation matrix that visually
represents the Pearson correlation
values between the different variables.
If we look at this,
we can see the total day charge and
the total day minutes has
a very bright red block,
meaning those variables
are highly positively correlated.
The values associated with
it are also 1, meaning,
they're perfect positive correlators.
To go even further, in the scatterplot
on the right hand side,
that you can see as
the total.day.minutes increases,
the total.day.charges moves
exactly in parallel with it.
I would say that not only are these
variables inter-correlated,
but they are duplicate variables.
With this being said,
we should remove one of the variables,
since they are redundant.
And having these duplicate
fields will cause
errors during the prediction
time of the analysis.
Looking at the list of potential
predictor variables again,
since the total.day.minutes field has
a slightly greater association to
turn than the total.day.charge field,
I will keep that field and
remove the total.day.charge field.
Let us now look at the full heat plot of
all the variables against each other.
By looking at the full graph,
I'm scoping out three things.
One, where are very red blocks?
These very red blocks represent highly
positively correlated variables.
The second thing I'm looking for, are
very blue boxes which represent highly
negative correlation between variables.
The third thing I'm looking for,
is little to no color,
what this represents is little
correlation between our variables.
Now we'll observe variables that
have very little correlation,
since these are the variables that
can be used as predictors together,
since they have very
little inter-correlation.
If we look at the total.intl.minutes
versus the total.eve.minutes
we can see that the correlation between
the two variables is very low at 0.02.
In the scatterplot,
we see no patterns and total randomness,
meaning that the movement in one
field does not effect the other.
This is exactly what we are wanting
in our predictor variables.